like the other day I was on a plane that
kinda was on fire and we just made an
emergency landing and then after we
landed the guy go say sorry didn't make
an announcement I had my hands full up
there which meant some sort of
nauseating light came on or he smelt it
smell like burnt popcorn I thought the
stewardess who were burning a dinner or
something was like it was a commercial
flight that was on fire yeah how far
into it were you uh that's a funny thing
we've gone Nashville to LA and we ended
up landing in Little Rock so like we
were in the air for like 40 minutes and
all of a sudden we started descending
and I was thinking going like all right
is they going underneath some you know
some turbulence or some [ __ ] and then
all of a sudden like drink started
sliding down like of the armrest I was
able to like wow I really going down and
the lady came by she goes yeah we're
collecting all the drinks cuz we're
gonna be landing shortly this is 40
minutes into Nashville to LA and the
woman next me takes her headphones off
she was like we're here already which I
would have done at some point in my life
I like trash and I just laughed I was
like now I got think we're making an
emergency landing she was like why goes
probably had to do with that burning
smell so uh I just to keep myself calm
like all right he's controlling the
aircraft he's dead you know he's flying
this [ __ ] thing it wasn't like that
autopilot [ __ ] like he was flying and so
my whole thing was like going oh my god
is it one of those [ __ ] cell phones
the galaxy seven that said you can have
a bag and they make the announcement
that when you get on the plane if you
have one of those tell us right now you
gotta take it off the plane they weren't
they were saying they might be powered
off now that like they can't be on the
plane yeah yeah and uh so I was just so
now is just as we were descending just
thinking like is this thing going to go
through some [ __ ] wire or some
hydraulics or some shy it's gonna cut
like I don't know anything about planes
or anything but so we came with coming
in and I looked out the window I thought
we were in st. Louis cuz I thought what
I saw was the Mississippi River but it
was just some river that feeds into it
outside a little rock so we're coming
for landing in like all I can look out
the side and all I see is trees in this
[ __ ] River and for half a second like
is this guy gonna Sully this thing and
put it in the water so then I was just
thinking stay conscious stay conscious
and I'm thinking I was to get everything
there's a frontal plane gets [ __ ] up
in that door that's right because I was
in the first seat yet I'm on the first
guy out and I'm not taking anybody with
me either hahaha i was saying if that
thing gets
crunched up and won't open up then I
gotta fight my way and you will fight
your way oh yeah I already stepping on
people's heads to get out of there but
that it would have been like you know
everybody trying to get up but then
fortunately I saw the runway then they
landed them like reverse engines please
reverse engines and then it's got to a
point of like even if we hit a fence we
were okay and I was like all right and
then we get off the plane there's like a
fire engine in people in like these
asbestos suits and [ __ ] but whatever the
[ __ ] did you go to the Gator do these
stay on the right away no went to the
gate we got off and they're all going
like there's like literally people in
like those beekeeper fire suits yeah in
a big fire engine on those airport ones
up against near the plane and they're
like okay we're going to see if this
thing we can still fly nobody's getting
back on that [ __ ] about it know then
they go all right we can't fly that uh
that we do have another plane for you
guys the problems is two hours away away
and the crews an hour away from the
plane and commendable crowd they're only
ten percent way oh gee there's no way to
run an airline just like dude this is a
great way to run an airline right we
could have just burned to death yeah
from 35,000 feet and this [ __ ] guy
knew what to do when he got us on the
ground safely shut the [ __ ] up yeah they
want an extra plane and a flight crew
there for every plane just in case any
of them catch on fire there yeah it's
not uber right another of jumbo jets not
showing up in five minutes to [ __ ]
little rock arkansas so what did you do
night which airlines or just hang out
wait no I just thought because I checked
a bag I was thinking about doing that
but even then like that air that Airport
was almost closed in town was the Bill
and Hillary Clinton airport and little
is it really oh yeah and I went up to
the bar I watched the razorbacks get
their ass kicked by Auburn and then i
watch the Cubs go to their first World
Series and just even being in a World
Series in 71 years it was great man I
had a couple of pops yeah I just chill
down I was just like no matter how long
it took I was like I didn't burn to
death right that's great man yeah that
and so then it took it to like one in
the morning we landed it like six and
they said the crew is going to be there
by eight thirty of the courses and now
it's nine that's 10 the usual [ __ ]
right trying to get jumbo jet there
right so everybody starting yell at
these [ __ ] people at the little rock
airport who should have been home six
hours earlier right then you know and so
finally we get on the plane like okay
this plane is going to take you back to
Dallas and we've never been to dallas
images so why you gotta get out it's
just like dude american airlines dallas
is their hub right they're gonna get
this word Little Rock you want to go
back to Nashville you [ __ ] idiot
right they just wanted to go like
directly to LA uh so then we get we get
there and then they wanted us to deplane
d then get back on the plane for
whatever [ __ ] reason I don't know and
this one guy here this guy go they can't
possibly expect us to ever fly this
airline again hey that he spoke for all
of us right it's just like dude I am
absolutely gonna fly this airline again
cuz they showed me that if one of their
planes is smoldering they can get me on
the ground safely yeah did you better
get that if they've been like an old
sock wearing content